Kevin and Astrid fall apart Colton and
Tia disappear and grocery store Joe
versus Leo with the fro it's time for
roses and rose hey hi everybody i'm
lauren zima and i am dressed like an
ocean because in paradise we ride the
waves we start off with jenna and benoit
kissing i hated watching this do you
Kristin Jenna and benoit had a real
connection or was a purely physical
there was a point where they were on the
beach and she was like and that made me
think it's physical and then there was a
point where she couldn't stop kissing
him and that made me think it's physical
anyway drink every time it's physical
mm-hmm you guys it's episode 72 and
ninety three of season five of bachelor
in paradise anyway whatever you guys are
here you've been watching you know
what's up let's talk about it I know but
very nice thank you thank you connor
arrives connor was from becca season
he's fine I mean he's fine he's good
he's tired like he is
Christel definitely you could tell had
been like attracted to him before and
maybe they'd even talked a little bit
before but then shrink every time you
were surprised crystal totally rejected
him but then drink every time you're
surprised again then she went back on
rejecting him after telling Chris that
she was gonna reject him she then went
to Connor and said no no I'm not
rejecting you what
that's paradise everybody paradise so
nice that things happen thrice and
you're confused all the time so yeah
don't drink every time you're confused
because that's a dangerous game on this
show okay benoît and jenna big poll
question do you like Benoit better with
glasses or without JC can you please pop
in to demonstrate how attractive one can
be with both methods but how it's
different and perhaps based on
preference everybody I'm dressed in this
dress like an ocean these are the waves
to me and JC is also dressed in blue we
didn't even plan this all right here's
Benoit / JC with the glasses ooh sexy
smoldering intelligent thoughtful
pensive and then here he is without
carefree ready to go at a moment's
notice
healthy visionary situation mmm
tough call everybody both Thank You JC /
Benoit
[Music]
Kenny is leaving because he doesn't want
to miss his daughter's recital I mean
you had to know about it beforehand you
know do you think Kenny should have left
I like Kenny and I think he deserves
love but I also understand why he had to
had to go and I just love how much he
prioritizes his daughter so cheers to
Kenny hope it's out there but I think
him and Annalise had more of a
friendship anyway and we'll see that
Annalise gets whiplash and turns around
real quick Camille Camille come on so
Mazel come meal arrives and I'm glad
Annalise is happy with him but you guys
what do you think of Camille I can't put
my finger on him there's something about
how his eyes like aren't connecting he's
like very dead behind the eyes like is
that just me I don't mean that in a mean
way it's just how it looked tell me I'm
also unclear on his accent he was on
Beca season so briefly and I thought he
was American so I guess I'm wrong what's
the deal what's the deal with Camille
well Annalise thanks the paradise gods
aka producers let's call it like it is
Joey shall we and then there ATVing on a
bridge and this looked very unsafe and I
had a lot of liability insurance
questions I mean I loved it at least but
I would not trust her to drive me got
that a narrow bridge and a motor vehicle
would you let me know and as we know the
family's she doesn't mean any more
traumatic experiences in her lives you
guys don't want any more
and Astrid were you guys shocked by
kevin time astrid he thinks that she
should date someone else drink every
time you're shocked mmm I was I couldn't
believe this they've had such a strong
connection been such a normalised drama
what drama-free couple in paradise I
feel like me and you connected so
quickly we haven't had to go through any
tests whatsoever and did you feel
differently once Kevin explained himself
I understood his logic he was basically
saying you know he was on Bachelorette
in Canada and then in winter games and
he's trepidatious he's cautious he's
careful he is hesitant what am I the
Souris cheers to being college-educated
someone could easily just like uncovered
me instagram referral is 34 years old
care about yeah so kevin also wow you
guys if we'd been drinking every time
the season he sneaks in some shade
against ashley i he talks about someone
hooking up with him just for Instagram
[Music]
um not that I think she did that but did
you then he was talking about Ashley I
because I did okay Jenna rejects Benoit
yay rejoice even though I like been want
a lot and I hope you find somebody else
but I just love Jenna and Jordan
together so much did you guys have a
preference for jenna benoit or jordan
there's a right answer anyway and then
do not drink every time we don't see
Colton and Tia because mama Mia
you would be drinking this entire
episode you guys this show does give us
whiplash because it's been the Colton
and TV show all season long I was in for
are they okay okay
do they drown are they still there and
then they kind of pop up I just I forgot
they were there I guess this is them
being Donald mmm I just spilled on my
new ocean dress dang it
anyway oh you win some you lose some you
paradise some okay Leo it gets weird
about this tattling thing with Kevin did
you agree with him I thought it was find
the Kevin told Kendall that Leo kissed
Chelsea I thought it was fine the
biggest issue people seem to have this
season on paradise is when someone's
just not honest about dating around like
everybody's totally into dating around
and making out around and being open but
you got to tell people what's up you
didn't tell me anything about Joey you
say there was you didn't say there was a
relationship you didn't say there wasn't
I mean I was focusing on our
relationship but you knew that was fair
you knew that was
who's right or wrong here Leo or Kendall
what do you think because Kendall really
came at him but Leo said that she didn't
really tell him the whole story about
her in grocery store Joe but are you
saying that it's for normal for you and
I would say it was a phenomenal feat
yeah you know this escalates Leo calls
Kendall up some nominal ashes see yikes
now I'm signing with Kendall just
because we as says some immature
crap she sees a handshake in paradise
[Music]
okay episode two two for Tuesday
we start off strong with Joe intervening
on the Leo and Kendall drama and up if
we didn't have enough of a reason to
love grocery store joke you're talking a
mild man he then consoles Kendall the
woman he's into about the other guy she
was dating on the side he consults her
about Leo I was shocked but not shocked
that he's so great I think I better do a
refill for episode two you guys I have
one of my favorite Rosie's here tonight
I'm not gonna say which one it is
because we're not sponsored but you can
probably tell by the bottle because it's
a pretty unique bottle shape and also it
has something to do with two very
high-level a lists actors who are now
splitting up and it's a very dramatic
split just like this is a very dramatic
show anyway mmm let me know in the
comments if you know what it is
Boop and tell me your favorite Rosie I
love to try new brands okay do not drink
every time some amazing guy consoles his
ladies side piece first Joe is consoling
Kendall over Leo then Jordan consoles
Jenna over Benoit
you're telling me to heal God Joe and
Jordan are amazing and I love their
friendship they have got all these cute
little moments together I love their
bromance and their romances you yelled
honor when I talked to her for the day I
didn't yell at her
so Jordan confronts Benoit in Wells
defendant been Wanda's no no he wasn't
yelling at Jenna but whose side are you
on here because I thought that Benoit
was just being honest with Jenna Benoit
Jordan I felt joy was being a little too
hard on Benoit and I like Jordan a lot
but Benoit seems like a nice chill guy
and I just felt he was trying to get
answers what did you guys think you
opened up my briefcase I don't like your
little French fingers going through it
you know that's it just stop open up my
briefcase bro
then Jordan talks about his briefcase
full of passion Jordan we purchased
patents that because we all need one
what's in your briefcase passion I just
want to have what you're having and I
want you to say crap about everything
and just narrate I just gotta love him
if my business was gonna be something I
was carrying would it be what would it
be your business yeah it would
definitely be like a travel duffel
[Music]
Benoit gets into Chelsea and I don't
mind this I think this could be good I
do think Ben was a pretty mature guy and
Chelsea's a single mom and she's mature
so great okay Eric and Angela oh look at
you you look - hey how you doing you
guys do you get this couple I don't get
it I'm surprised by it but they had a
great date with a bathtub full of
champagne maybe they could have brought
some back for their cast mates then they
had a huge ice cream sundae it was like
home alone - in there to scoop sir -
make it three I'm not trying
okay now Kendall and Jean are together I
am exhausted and I will say as much as
I'm okay with riding the waves of the
paradise whiplash it doesn't take much
for people to kiss in paradise does it
Kendall and John are hanging out and
John's just like a fine
I like that
okay and then they kiss it's not that
hard to make someone feel good for five
minutes when you're just having a normal
conversation you know it doesn't merit a
tongue swap I'm falling for you too so I
get it
I think it's good to be scared I can't
with Kendall putting Joe to the side
anymore so thank God they figured it out
because I was getting exhausted and it's
traumatizes Annalise Kendall and Joe yay
[Music]
Leo is not done with the drama Paradise
needs to burn to the ground start fresh
because that's what we need to do he
says Kindle is full of Sh I you know how
that word and scene
this isn't T but we are spilling the tea
then Joe goes to defend Leo and it
sounds a bit he called him grocery store
you know what and just like to say that
to my face
and then it was just really funny to me
the way that Leo did say into his face
cuz he just kind of like said it really
like he just could barely handle saying
it to his face
and then he throws a drink and then
things get dramatic and then I love when
this happens the fourth wall is broken
the producers have to run in oh and I
love them all and if you follow any of
them on Instagram we had Natalie Shabtai
in there and a guy everybody calls Spitz
in there and oh love a producer moment
they had a Russian and just stop the
fighting
go on back to the jungle leo nobody
wants you here see you later bye bye
oh and then Lia was just gone I guess
buying all of the guys but are not
coupled up
[Music]
David everybody's after Chelsea and you
know what she deserves it Chelsea
deserves this she's gorgeous and
wonderful and I don't know why more men
aren't into her go Chelsea then Colton
and Tia share a hot dog I figured if
you're missing the South the least I
could do is bring the south to you I
don't know how to feel about this it
wasn't romantic to me I kept thinking
that the hotdogs are cold and sitting
out in the humidity it was such a large
pile of hotdogs I thought that had to
take a long time to make all those
hotdogs and say they've just been
sitting there and being like Lady and
the [ __ ] stick with the hot dog would
you guys think this is sexy maybe I'm
wrong I don't know what the kids are
into these days but that's gonna be a no
for me send me some flowers okay so also
I love it cuz we cut to Kevin and Astrid
who are both so fit and they're eating
like a plate of veggies John Tosi pick
John were you surprised
I sure was didn't see a common thought
she'd go for Benoit why is everybody so
into John you guys I think John's sweet
but like it's Chelsea actually into him
what do you think do you actually find
John attractive tell me
okay Benoit leaves and he's crying and
sweating or is he sweating and not
crying he's swaying that's what people
do in paradise their credit Olivia gets
there I don't remember her Cassie from
Juan Pablos season what a throwback
Cassie asks Erik on a date and from here
the rest of the episode was kind of wild
to me because people kept saying that
Eric and Angela had been rock-solid
since the beginning I barely knew they
were a couple until very recently and I
barely heard Angela talk until this
episode really especially the end and
then I felt so bad her because she was
crying so much because Eric wasn't
treating her right so who do you side
with Erik or Angela I'm falling on the
side of Angela that's pretty much it you
guys don't drink every time she cried
but what a week it was I continued to
love this season of bachelor in paradise
how am i okay I'm as I've had a long day
everybody I was at a shoot that I shoot
as an interview situation that I can
only tell you about but I'm you'll see
let me know what you guys thought of
these episodes as always are you at the
point where you're wondering which
couples are gonna stay together until
the end and if so who do you want to
stay together who do you want to be
engaged let me know I love you all so
much thank you so much for watching
roses and Rose a and we'll be back next
week next Wednesday morning with another
new episode we are closing down on this
season paradise rapidly I don't want it
to end I love you ride the wave
[Music]